all right and we are live welcome to the
last word episode number 77 and it's
another glorious Friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some great
ludis shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a Lord who's always been one
of the most welcoming and passionate
content creators within our entire
destiny community whether it be is in
entertaining live streams informative
ranking videos this Lord is energy
personified and has recently put the
trimmings on neck guard the salvation
introducing the host of the scarin on
YouTube channel and legion observe
destiny claim recently deemed unbroken 9
in the realm of the crucible and Lord of
other chickens everywhere loved by the
campfire and making his return into the
realm of the last bird my man no it's
Cairo 9 how you doing sir
I'm doing very well I got to take a bow
or something there's not really a way to
ever live up to those intro so you just
got to blow past it just you know what
whatever by the way I hereby I'm on the
reddit kind of train of calling Garden
salvation actually the vault of grass
all the grass credit to him that is
great dude man it has been a crazy week
I know for you it's been insane like
you've spent hours upon hours in the
topic of the day yeah you've been a
black you know it's been it's been
awesome so we've got a lot of stuff
going on this week we've got gardener
also valley shouldn't launched basically
the day after the podcast went live last
week so of course always a day later
than everything we had best offensive
launch at the same time which took most
of us two days later to get to because
we were all rating and then sleeping
yeah we have new difficulties in
Nightmare hunts armour 2.0 to talk about
so quite a few topics in you to get into
but
first thing is this gigantic awesome
raid that we got to jump into and scare
oh you are the man of the hour so well
you get the dibs first and just kind of
want to go 30,000 foot just like over
all of you like thoughts when you walked
like thoughts when you went in the big
stuff just kind of overall how you
thought about the whole thing yeah yeah
absolutely so just a little bit back
i've spent according to raid report 27
hours in the raid over the past week too
much too much but most of those dying i
have for completion so far hopefully
board it comes to know we've already
done like divinity itself so i'm not i'm
trying to flex or anything just trying
to establish credibility chest sandwich
Cheska four-time champ you know not
first anyway so yeah this rate
incredibly well done for many reasons
perfectly sized read I think for
encounters with a couple of jump puzzles
beautiful the difficulty going in
contests is amazing hopefully they find
some way to maybe have like an optional
contest in the future that's never done
something like that yeah
so so so good and honestly like just the
the flow of the raid as well as the
uniqueness of some of the mechanics and
Wow some of them because I was rating at
times yeah Congo line for Congo line is
is single-handedly one of the most you
and most frustrating especially in the
final boss but I mean it's I I think
they have one for the ages here it's
it's it's it's in top 5 I don't what's
that what's that list it with Teflon
okay okay so top 5 this is hard right so
we'll go top three because it moves
around quite a top three right now
number one last wish I think Lord when
did he throw there you go number it's
here we're gonna go with Rafa Dean
that's a in my eyes the the perfect
one raid that's what or a bunch of
rather really found their footing and
then the third one no one's gonna
disagree with this this is a very
contentious thing you know okay I get
last wish I did it
you don't Sam um rattle sheet very fun
read love that rate yeah but my question
is I've noticed to raise omitted from
that three one be the iconic fault of
glass what I like to call a man's rate
demands they take a king's fall you
gotta help explain like how did those
two not make it into that three oh
that's easy because they're not Kurt
isn't but hello everybody this is gonna
sound a little weird for a second but we
had some technical difficulties in the
middle of this podcast so as best as
possible it can a slice these two
segments together
there weren't exactly the same move so
we kind of rerecord it a little bit
there but I hope you enjoy the podcast
and again thank you guys for supporting
all of us this one is a ton of fun a lot
of raid talking here so have a blast and
enjoy so we were at the part where Scout
was saved some sacrilegious things so we
put the care fire up this is a very
passionate thing in a respect to Lord
scare oh you don't say I want to hear
his thought process as to why now he has
one of the goats in these top three so I
kind of respect to me as last wish in
the hello
rat rat is great it's close for me but
no it's not about me right this is that
about we're good to me this is about you
you are the guest you are live at the
campfire so my question is why does
taken King and fall to glass oh not
crack the top three let's get in
so as I just kind of a recap of what I
said was like quote four kings fall
first part of that raid is I mean you
don't get anything I think it's like a
ghost shell comes from totems and that's
the first like reward you can get maybe
the fusion came from it as well as it's
been a long time mmm first part of that
raid is a time suck Oh a big big time
sake mmm then that raid suffers from two
two encounters or two yeah two
encounters that suffer from something I
call the Oryx problem or the orcs
pandemic
which is when there's an encounter that
no matter how good you are you cannot
short you are required to go X amount of
times so totems you obviously have to do
that and the really annoying one which
was Oryx especially Oryx because you
would it's a great fight don't get me
wrong but you never do damage to the
boss you know you have to go for circles
you have to detonate 16 plates at the
end and so if you spend 10 minutes
getting to the fourth one and all of a
sudden a light eater night comes and you
know everybody has to do their job
there's no speed falling I feel like so
those two encounters being totems and
Oryx I are really specifically worse
it's really good but i hate i will i'm a
i'm a person like let's get in let's get
out let's get it done you know my gonna
be on there more priests in an
incredible encounter very well done
golgoroth if if people did it as it was
supposed to be done an incredible
encounter but one orc strategy ruined
golgoroth when
just like ribbon she's ruined ribbon
okay I'll see what you going with that
yeah it just kinda it makes the entire
encounter obsolete and then another
thing I very much dislike is when so
Bungie has this kind of tendency in a
lot of raids to do like a phase 1 phase
to get final boss where phase 1 is
teaching you like the base mechanics
phase 2 is implementing those on a
larger scale yes sisters is such a
boring encounter it's so boring
it's it's just like you might be on to
someone with sisters you might be honest
own with sister I left that one in the
same way like phase 1 of spire stars the
ships destroyed that one sucks it's it's
it's a miniature version of the final
boss that is not as rewarding
emotionally or in-game right like it's
just like oh now we have to do sisters
to get through Oryx also in sisters you
couldn't think who the runner was
whereas you know like I would always be
the runner I was always like on a hunter
bones Mao with race lighter that was
like the runner setup sister she
couldn't do that you know it's just if
you had a warlock on your team good luck
to me the flu flu game I actually got
pretty damn good at my title I was very
good like I think somatically in in
concepts but I feel like just the time
it came out was it was a big jump
obviously going from it I mean it's the
size of both of glass and crotas end put
together yeah I said that's a rage rate
yeah but I feel like at that point in
destiny at least my team personally
wasn't ready for that jump there are
some very aggravating mechanics in terms
of you can't shorten the like I said the
aurochs pandemic and then you also have
the sisters and I mean war priest and
and the dick wall puzzle shout out to
them
also hopeful we got to finish appointed
and I'm gonna ask you about fall right
now okay just uh just a kind of one
thing that I really respect about Kings
fall and it's something that I hope
Bungie keeps doing is it was kind of the
first time that they started to put like
Easter eggs and raids in that I feel
like that with the the basketball court
right it's commonly overlooked and that
I feel like was the natural kind of
first step to go to something like
outbreak or divinity and I really
respect that and I love that I just I
just I feel like if I were to go back
and ask them to do the rate differently
there's a lot of things I would change
about Kings fall and both of glass now
that's a whole different thing with
vaulted glass is then everyone holds it
to such a high regard it's like it's
just not okay so first off once again
first three encounters we're building
the spire which is a class okay that's
that's a sense that's essentially a meme
at this point not rewarded Oracle's and
con flexes not really rewarding I think
don't give you a drops Cal has to track
the points let's just get to it I have
like 40,000 weapon parts are one of the
most rewarding have fun and then the
little what is it de siiva keys that
give me the thing understanding the
scare oh absolutely it's it's a time
investment to resource output kind of
thing I really I mean don't get me wrong
like Leviathan is a very rewarding rate
as well but that's like a middle tier
rate a mess right continue the rate
[Laughter]
continual slander let me hear this so in
terms of like overall mechanics volta
classes okay
gatekeeper you don't really need to do
the mechanics most the time just cool in
terms of like the one thing I really
liked about worklist was how the music
aspect played into like this like like
the alpha lupi war and that's what
that's that's really freaking cool I I
love that you know and then especially
how they keep referencing both the glass
so like throughout the whisper mission
and that's what that's really cool
mm-hmm and also the the kind of
community searching for the six chests
and that sort of very very cool I just I
feel like it was a it was an amazing
starting point it was an absolutely
fantastic first raid of Destiny first
yes raid ever I think backs it was
excellent and I respect the hell out of
it for what it did but if vault of glass
never came out and it came out next
expansion people would not have it you
know I would agree with that
I would agree yeah it was it was an
amazing starting point and I respect it
for what it did but if I'm being as
objective as possible and talking about
my pure enjoyment of raids and like how
amazing the raids feel and how good the
mechanics are it doesn't touch last wish
and it sure as hell doesn't touch rat
you know like it nobody read Pablo I got
last wish I cannot fight you on it
those are my true and beyond as much as
I'm slandering red and I love red why I
like it's it's really tough for me to
place cuz I had so much fun with it and
I said my only nitpick T in response to
you if I had to counter with Reb as much
as I loved it
the guy I call him the Cable Guy the guy
that you know you're the TVs in the back
and you know you don't know yes I called
we we kind of my issue with um sometimes
with raids is that I like I don't like
to sometimes face the same thing
throughout so when I saw him initially
and we were doing the little charges
okay cool and then he runs off and it's
not okay cool sometimes I don't I want
to see that's what I like taken King to
some I just want to see different bosses
sometimes I like
like more different encounter respect
the same guy but that's just a personal
choice there's nothing really wrong with
rats and machine and in turn in your
point it's really rewarding one of the
funniest moments where I think was
putting the engine together with the
tiny fails yeah yeah shout out to Westar
what's the little guy mimics whatever
the guy on the top if you don't kill him
what about the outbreak quest though I
mean that mean I would binary for that
quest
just like I that's that's another thing
is it's kind of the the raine exotic and
a lot of the raid we've also really
plays like a really fundamental role to
how I remember that raid and and how
good the armor looks to you right in
Kings fall transrapid Williams terminus
preach yeah the sniper and whatever the
pulse rifle was was alright yeah yeah
but you're right the weapons that is not
rewarding Kings and even the main exotic
the one with the the little odd and
touch of malice you can't use it really
anywhere else yeah that's where Kings
fall it takes a lot of points for me I
didn't feel the reward to drops for all
that oh yeah you like will its armor for
the age of triumph second best right
behind crotas end with the ornaments all
those that's still some of the best time
we've ever had yeah absolutely dude
that's the one thing about crotas end
you had we had guys and one the coolest
fricking weapons ever like in terms of
just like that was one of the first
super unique exotics I feel like we had
in terms of like not only looking and
sounding cool but also doing something
pretty freaking cool as well obviously
necrochasm when it's shed a light some
of the exotics we haven't destiny to now
but it was an amazing starting point
and then black hammer yeah that in
itself if the black hammer never existed
the destiny would be an incredibly
different game right because that led to
the original whisper mission which led
to this whisper mission which lets you
literally the meta that we have right
now so there's so freaking cool I just
encourage that has the coolest color
scheme in my opinion the white blooms
let's talk slammed it now what about
well okay it was cool going down but if
you really look at it it's like three
womb like the lanterns the bridge and
then like hallway stage yeah we go say
no but that's what you just say I loved
being like this I really do I wanted the
one of the things that like really got
me passionate about the game was you
know raiding and talking about raids and
learning the ins and outs of everything
and I think there's some rates that have
like a float:right like a really good
story driven really nice flow and I use
rap as an example of this all the time
because you start on the outside of the
wall you work your way in and then up
top I'll walk along to get to the server
front back right very very good flow the
entire time throughout card is end IR
excuse me um Kings fall it was just kind
of like you know we're in the dread-nots
already and it's just like one random
room after another right wait there's no
sense of like oh we're getting closer to
Oryx unless you've already done the raid
then you know but like just like going
into the if I were to put you in more
priests for the first time you couldn't
tell me if you were 2 or 10 encounters
away from or x-ray I think that's one
thing you kind of cycling back around
that
salvation does really well the flow of
this raid isn't yeah read about yeah
guarding on the moon outside of the
black garden yeah
going into kind of like the beginning of
the entire thing
and then once again kind of making your
way progressively to the top of the
black garden cuz you know it's like a
bunch of plateaus with under areas no
just it's very rewarding and it has a
very kind of grandeur feeling as you're
as you're conquering different parts of
the raid and getting closer and closer
to the end and you can really tell
especially towards like the final jump
puzzle that you're really getting
somewhere it's big it's increasingly
beautiful encounters get increasingly
more difficult and it's really it really
climaxes and reaches an apex right
before the sanctified mind and it's
beautiful it's very well done very good
flow already has the divinity which is
incredible so many secret areas and
puzzles and stuff my only worry is
because they gave us divinity so early
on it's like right how is that gonna
hold up like that's a lot of time for
puzzles that we don't really get to
flesh out and explore for more than a
week so how how is that gonna go is
there more in store for us in this range
right and so that's that's you know not
your based one your flow logic I
understand now why last wish is Liam
dear to you because you think of
something like coming into it you know
you fighting the first initial Kali but
to me one of the thing that encapsulates
what you're talking about is the Shero
Chi encounter absolutely and I love that
so me and you are here the air arms to
that encounter because I shut out to the
music when that account add music
animatic on is phenomenal we go towards
yo like just that race against time
going through each and going up the side
of the you know the castle and that
whole thing man I love it love it love
it so I'm definitely which you on and
out again please come back my question
now is as far as on just this is
nitpicking that we just nitpicking
greatness cuz it's a lot of great this
we talking about in reference to armed
guard of salvation my question is
how do you feel about not necess my only
little nitpick like not necessarily
having like an iconic boss or that yeah
is this guy like definitely a thing that
I've actually expressed concerned about
and I think one of the the things is
actually like you know you talked about
sorry my cat
one of the things I've kind of talked
about it and you actually mentioned was
like the flow into the rave like we have
story reasons to go into the raid
because the artifact and stuff but one
thing you know I don't you know you guys
have been it so hopefully I'm not
spoiling any it just says the artifact
no ants you you need nothing happens
it's just it just literally just ants
and it's like I want one part I feel
like we're not done with it yet like
there's gotta be some sort of like you
know the end cutscene for the campaign
just kind of ants but really you're
making a way straight to the raid after
that yeah I feel like there's like
another piece of the puzzle that we just
haven't been given yet and I'm doing I
don't have the flow on
but that's highs in so like who the boss
is in it it matters a little bit less
cuz in the war you know we just we're
just kind of like we got sort of
summoned in a way to the blood garden
and yeah we don't know we're not
expecting anything you know we go to the
dry not expecting Oryx
Rai Rai we go into Curtis and expecting
CRO in the last wish expecting Riven
exactly like yeah I'm literally tells us
you have to slay ribbet exactly and this
at the beginning of this raid eros is
like I don't know what the hell you're
gonna there's obviously something good
so how's it really cool I mean the boss
is essentially Megatron right that's
kinda cool it was there it was the
vaulted glass lander
one thing I think would have really
helped us we know that the undying mind
plays a really big role in this season
and is gonna play a really big role in
vex offensive I think it would it's at
least an idea to play with if Bungie
would have taken the sanctified mind and
switched them with the undying Minds
yeah because the undying mind you know
we've already killed twice you know a
destiny one obviously in the shuttle to
yamaga loop yeah what's the first strike
called was it was it just the undying
mind I think so what was the PlayStation
exclusive one with the imago weave what
was that one called may you take it be
back
oh okay I remember off top so we've
already killed him twice I think it
would've been really cool cuz like he
got more powerful and you got more
abilities the second time I think it
would be really cool if he became even
more powerful the third time and yeah
it's kind of the ideology of like every
time you kill him he just gets stronger
and stronger and stronger right I think
that would've been cool and then we also
have this other big bad who is you know
kind of causing the entire yes offensive
thing right I mean at the end of the day
it's a raid boss he's really fun to kill
I don't know if a hydra like the undying
mind would have had the same effect as a
giant Minotaur I mean cuz minotaurs are
like very physically imposing they're
very like big bad yeah he's a big big
dude he's a big he's like yes he said
Megatron big he's huge yeah what am I
pyro actually pointed out that it's
essentially you like Bungie took do you
guys remember at the very end of year
one I think prophy on into the inverted
spark which where he was like ten times
his size and I was like that guy's stuck
in the rain so it's that's very imposing
a worse than I expect a hydra would me
that's a good point that is a great
point that's a good but it's one of
those things like I have to see
on it for a while at the moment am i a
little bit disappointed that there's not
really a war tie-in yeah but I also was
with axis and axis is one of my favorite
boss fights of all time so I'm sad he
didn't get the law he deserved because
he was cool I like cool I actually don't
know if you guys know this but in the in
the intro cutscene where Shaq's is in
Ferrara Saladin's are from the wall and
then like the splicers come out at the
very end for like two seconds you can
see like axis is the legs like come down
just in the corner of the screen oh you
see that's it dope so you're saying I've
got something like weed up it is what it
is
you know I see this this boss fight even
though he's kind of a unknown kind of
guy I see it having a lot of replay
value just because it's a lot of fun
it's very reminiscent it's kind of like
a Theon if it was done nowadays right
like a Theon two or three more mechanics
right that's actually what it is is a
peon in gambit mechanic to do with it
does almost no don't II
yeah yeah I'm just I'm just hosting this
thing you guys got this is so no I mean
you guys have been covered a bunch of
stuff I mean a lot of even just the
opening counter set the stage for the
the amount of movement that we would
need in the raid just to start out from
like make the conga line open the door
okay three you guys go light that is not
how you normally start a raiding counter
it's like you might have a rotation you
might be defending points you might be
in teams but it's not just like book it
okay now the three of you now then you
go ahead and then the final section
encounters wish if she wrote she was
first and that's not ya know and that
last encounter though when you come
because you have you have the entrance
stage reopen the first or the second one
you come up the third door after the
third door and
that's kind of one of the things the
visual reveals like when you turn the
corner and you see the wall of cyclopses
or like people have said and I haven't
done the reveal to the last moss but
seeing the last boss like the reveals
two sections of this rain have been so
visually well DLC dude with the pyramid
ship as well oh yeah Corner game is on
that's like a cinematic director just
like okay I want this shot so we need to
put a wall here so they walk around the
corner they see it it was late sorry if
you haven't heard that terminology
before that's all you're gonna what they
are no yeah so even that first encounter
and we my team got to that last section
like we just kind of put things together
in that last section we wandering the
guy I was like this far away from
picking up the last one and then we were
like stuck on that for another hour and
like finally got through but that first
section so we're like used to running
and run and I'm like well go go and
everything we can but it's like that
frantic nature and that's also for me
one of the reasons why I mean you
mentioned crota and for me I have a
special saw up for kurtal one because of
like one of my best friends and I we -
man dips flawlessly and that's the one
of my favorite things that I've ever
done so I didn't even solo flawless it
was just he and I though and we did it
like literally in like four or five like
three or four hours practicing
encounters went through knocked it out
and it was just like and it just somehow
came together but the opening of crota
for me it's no been always a really cool
thing because it's the theme of that
raid is hive it's frantic and all of
those pieces and that's why I've always
thought the curta rate has a good theme
to it as you said it's like room
connected to room connected room like
taking king is like okay yeah you
wouldn't know but it's like you know
you're pushing closer towards Croat
you're crossing a bridge or going
through you're like you are getting
closer to a point but it's just like the
I just like the frantic nature of it so
that's one of those things and
Incognito's about to just like bust it
right now I just try to you know I try
to be to things that I okay you've got
you've got like vex you got vault of
glass wheel
okay like you know makes you guys stand
on these plates and then the pool no I'm
no I'm not arguing that that's like hey
stand here aligns like literally like a
lion stars basically or align everything
and then it opens like a key and I was
like and then the complete opposite it
was always a really cool thing Bungie
did they took it to the complete
opposite like race to for us to fight
and it was like okay you want to stand
still run you have to run the entire
time like and that was just a complete
flip so that one I was that was really
cool so that was just kind of just the
contrast of those two races loner always
yeah I just like to hear the mentality
as to why people you know the people who
love it who revere it like you gotta
hear why yeah so that when you're no go
ahead
oh okay so just sorry real quick I just
playing on this I think the first
encounter of a raid is like super
important I think the biggest example of
that is crown of sorrow that would be
near perfect in my eyes I mean not for
that first encounter it is so tedious no
one wants to do it suffers from that you
know works syndrome it you can't shorten
it and there's been way too many times
where we spent 10 minutes on this
encounter just to die on the last one
because everyone's so bored that they're
just having a fast pace yes first
encounter really sets the stage its own
raids that i watch so things like boss
ik beautiful because you know you have
to do stuff kings fold this an alright
job of this with the the basketball but
then it slows right back down because
the first jump puzzle is 20 minutes of
waiting for ships to allege to go yeah
and then totems is like 90% standing in
place shooting boomers out of door right
like so I guess that's more of like a um
that that's more of a me thing but yeah
I like raids that go and then never stop
right in what you continuity and I get
you like you know for me I think we're
mean you share that was with um wrath I
call it the dodgeballs like I thought
that was cool cuz sometimes
for most let's be honest most of these
rays generally have a mechanic that
tends to be a theme throughout the right
right so I thought it was the funniest
thing ever that we're picking up the
Ziva belittle dodge balling this guy I
guess like this yes twice you know
saying so no one was cool about the
second parties I love the part of
sliding underneath the little room is to
save the white dollar again III get it I
think I said just bring this all back in
you know like I said we know Gardens new
I think you're completely onto something
just that whole u-turn wall and you're
like oh we gotta get up daily like a
cinematography like directors like a
setting up visual shots in this play cuz
when you come up in that first part with
the line of cyclopses you're moving so
fast you can't tell the review is like
one of our best shot of the black garden
ever that you're gonna see up there is
like everything from the top end outside
of probably the end but yeah yeah it's
so cool to come up there and yeah just
like the amazing the visuals in this one
we're like hey we got to see the black
curtain a little bit me like okay now
we're going like all in through sideways
up around through leaves youngin like
there's so much cool looking stuff from
this one so first thing water was for me
like just set the tone as he said it was
really really cool no I agree but I
think this is this is really cool
Tom will tell we have we still have a
challenge mold right we got a yeah that
coming up and you know I'm curious what
that's gonna be what's gonna be about
you know yeah overall definitely please
gotta let it settle in a little bit more
for me but definitely definitely a solid
rate for sure so and then to come to the
other side of the raid what do you get
from the raid we get rewards how do you
guys feel the rewards are in this raid I
think it's pretty good I mean a lot of
people argue like the written thing on
the armor do I think that the phenotype
plasticity or whatever armor should have
been the raid armor yes yes yes I do
oh the season the season pass is an
ornament yeah those things
yeah uh but at the same time I genuinely
like this raid armor I am I'm a big fan
of like really I mean I already
explained like I really love the crow to
end like colors like anything that's
like super bright and neon II
specifically if it's in like the
blue-green range honestly so good this
armor does it really well so is it
technically a reskin of so my reverse
armor yeah yeah hey that doesn't matter
as much it looks good they obviously
were trying to piece as many people as
possible they had pool a couple cuts
whatever so I think the armor is really
good the weapons are very interesting
talk to me about our first pulse rifle
ever that can land rabid hit and it is a
four round burst beautiful I have an
outlaw kill clip the hand cannon sorry I
don't know any of the name yeah it's
beautiful functions very well the
divinity is like tractor can in 12 point
oh really break it down for me because I
had even I've been staying away from
like any videos on it and stuff like
that yes theoretically give me what's
the functionality of this way so what
divinity does so if you remember some of
the promo leading up to it you shoot it
it's like cold heart but it creates a
critical like a vex bubble like an
attainment bubble on an enemy and
anything that hits that bubble is
automatically a critical hit shot so you
don't need to wind like on there
critical hit like say the third boss you
don't have to shoot his eye if you hunt
with izanagi's anywhere it's a critical
hit in addition I believe it's a 25% I
could be wrong on that could be 35 I
believe it's 25% damage buff that stacks
with any other buff in the game so now
you can have one block one debuff and
that's all at the same time so this is
their way of circumventing the whole way
everybody was freaking out about well
and weapons and the stacking this is
their way they want us to get seem like
they're pushing us to utilize exotics or
these weapons exactly pose to just okay
exactly so it takes I mean this entire
thing like the divinity in itself takes
izanagi's from the best web
into like whisperer 2.0 I'm like baby I
got my cat late there you go it's it's
awesome the divinity is an amazing
weapon it's not as great solo like it's
still a pretty good weapon you never
have to reload it that sort of thing the
you know the critical hit damage lasts
for a little bit like as soon as you
stop shooting it doesn't go away like
you have a classroom okay the one
negative to divinity is there are
certain bosses in the game that have
kind of been termed by the community red
red bar critical bosses we're talking so
red bar enemies previous to this update
like throwing stuff have like I believe
a 2.0 critical modifier right and so the
divinity just puts a regular critical
modifier on them so you if you use
divinity against things like ribbon or
Shiro Chi or Kali or not even the
sanctified mind the final boss it
actually ends up doing less damage than
if you didn't use it just because it
undermines that extra modifier you
already get however on things like
callous you're fine you do more damage
on things like the I gotta raise my hand
I got I got some track points now now
you're telling me
great exotic of your great going to
salvation is not effective against the
boss encounter just fine I'm subtracting
points yeah no this is not top three
issue I think Bungie will probably fix
in the future what's the what's the
third bosses name so sanctify it's the
final boss victim some it's another mind
it's the big ass Hydra but I'm trying to
remember yeah I don't really conceived
mine or something good well it works
against him just fine you can one phase
off fairly easily poco it isn't Auggie's
if the go-to strat now bow well with
Lunas and then
the debuff magnetic grenade that on mine
well it does have to be magnetic but
that's the best because it mice and it
sticks to him so if you have that bubble
with weapons of light 35% buff as well
as the 25% debuff what's divinity and
the wound effects well o1 face with
easily oh no I'm working off this
consecrated mind consecrated consecrated
consecrated thank you yes no cat-like
soul whatever consecrated mine so yeah
yeah soul inherent consecrated mind yes
I'm like that but yeah I mean that's
it's kind of interesting to know yeah I
don't think if it works I feel like
that's somehow they like classified a
boss wrong if it's not actually damage
like how axis was actually like a spider
tank so exotic and grant are three of
coins and you got them it's one of those
weird no I was just kind of curious like
what you guys thought from cuz we're
talking about like previous raids and
things like that you go from things I
mean we had the Fate bringers we had you
know things like about the work you know
really good we had things like cocoon
that have like you know taking Kings
specific and then we've been kind of
progressing more and more it's like
obviously Leviathan you know had it had
good rolls and had good set rules like
people still lovely like like that I
actually had some of them mods like
weapons and now we just get to one worth
now the weapons can roll combinations of
things that other things can well you
can get I'm trying to think what the
combination is that I saw recently on
like an auto rifle with like no but go
to the last wish and it's just going on
it's like yes you can did last wish have
any lake outside of a thousand voices
that last wish have any weapons that you
really like really loved or wanted I
like nation would have whatever was call
it nation to the beast was it auto no I
got the narrator roles I was i I need to
pour my Dib
yeah let's go too many guns in this game
we're so busy
mr. privacy man supremacy with snapshot
was the best sniper in the game yeah so
there are some but it's like okay so I
guess here's the idea I'm going after
you going from no you go vision of
confluence like like you know epic
energy autoscout you've got fate bringer
then you have like you have mere black
cameras you have fine Patek Smith the
class that's in there too right but it's
like everyone they had like I feel like
the perks the weapons like the unique
nature of things that came from the Wade
raids in destiny one hasn't quite been
their destiny to there have been perks
there's been like you know nation of
beasts like a really good hand cannon
roll that I've got I'm just like I got
the curated like magically on my first
one and everybody is like I hate you and
I'm like I just got lucky but still
either way it's like yeah I got the
curated nation of beasts with like
outlaw and dragon fly and it explodes
everything but you know that being said
it's like what are we get into this one
yes we are now they're starting to do
okay so how do we not make guns that are
there they continue to seem to be afraid
of breaking things we don't have
we have ritual weapons now instead of
pinnacle weapons they're not like adding
that many more perks into the pool they
haven't like so I just kind of wonder
your guys thoughts about and this is
kind of just one of the topics to go
through but it's like well so when it
comes to the rate it's like yeah we now
have combinations that typically aren't
possible say like an auto rifle comes
with like rapid hit or something like
bananas like that that might be cool but
do you guys think that is enough I guess
that's kind of the point
alright you got your hand up go for it
oh yeah this way I'm at see business I'm
glad you see work in the show right now
so I mean here's the deal like I get
they're in a tough spot because you know
according to Luke and you know all these
things as destined players that we do we
find we we do things to break this game
for them we like we we really feel sorry
for those hotels because somebody
accommodate you come up with so I get
the whole err on the side of caution
with making Wade
it's kind of like Opie but on the other
side I do kind of go I'm kind of leaning
your direction which is that I just want
unique traits from these weapons that
could be only found on these weapons
like it doesn't excite me no disrespect
this car doesn't excite me when he's
like yeah it's got this in this
combination that maybe the LK yeah
doesn't maybe another gun can't have
that specific company but it's basic
perks we already see you know they like
and then my other thing now Scout
correct me if I'm wrong I start gonna
ask you because you are the r8 expert
here for garden so my question is like
you know I was hoping that of the old
Ray's where the weapon like you you had
a weapon that helped you in the mechanic
now I heard a rumor that there's mods
that do that that you can get some mods
that help you yeah
right now those those are armor mods
right yeah right so my I guess my
question I think I'm going at is like I
just wish that some of the weapons also
had that flare you know I'm saying yeah
like again for the go Oh had like you
know shooting the Oracles and things you
know doing extra damage against this and
you know just to help you with the ink I
just wish they kind of give that
uniqueness back that's where I'm at with
it so I feel like that's a really good
point
I feel like Bungie kind of put
themselves in a weird situation where
they couldn't do that this time though
because you have the overload and
barrier champions
ya know you pretty much have to be
running like Rover clues with barrier
mod at all times zoom especially during
the second encounter and then also
barrier through Hydra shields and
invincible hobgoblins as well so is it
really good for the last encounter yeah
so I feel like if they would have added
another layer on top of that like
another Mon slide you have been getting
to a weird spot because keep in mind you
know we don't have weapons 2.0 right
like there's no limit mods you can put
on you just do and so I feel like that
would have been really weird and put it
in a maybe felt too powerful and I'm not
even sure what they could do there's not
many like super unique enemy types in
this raid right um so I get what you're
saying but
I feel like especially with them just
releasing armor 2.0 I feel like having
an additional mod slot and really
keeping the focus on on that system at
least for the time being I think that
was the smart move because I mean
there's mods that you get an over shield
I believe whenever you are carrying a
certain amount of motes
there's mods and all of these mods have
a basic and enhanced version as well
oh there's mods that you get damage
resistance when you are tethered and
then there's a mod that you do
additional damage whenever you're in
front of an ActiveX relay so like the
and the 30 counter the thing you put
motes into UI rather and you're shooting
a boss you now do more damage not let's
see I like that oh yeah that's very cool
so I get what you're saying and I think
for raids like especially like Les Brown
or something right maybe recluse
shouldn't be the best and there should
be something to help out maybe you like
with I'm just gonna take away but I feel
like for the where we are in destiny in
2.0 beings gonna swatch tinsukia
prevalent I feel like this was the right
move right now back to your point you
brought it to the - okay no that's just
kind of what I was trying to get it I
always wonder and this is the England
they're not doing weapons 2.0 right now
the big focus is an armor so they have
mods in there which are cool you can get
the unlocks versions for enhanced and
things like that it does just feel at
some point like it's something we would
a lot of people I keep hearing listen to
different places it's something I would
like to see more variation on weapons
making the raid grind like worthwhile
it's like the other armor school and
looks cool and you get different you
know you can use different mods in there
but I can also if I get a good
substitutional alloy I can use the same
mods in that that I can in the raid so
another thing that makes it distinct
there's not like and even for me like
what I was wondering it's like and this
is something I've kind of be getting
more clarification on to is the status
on the armor that we're getting those
don't seem to go above about mid-60s
from whatever yeah I think 63 is the
highest yes I think AG has had like 65
like that's that's about the highest but
I mean even with that I was hoping
somewhere in on the raid would come
peak in a little bit higher maybe just
like even low 70s to make it worthwhile
on people and some people were saying
because I was talking to my chat the
other day and they were saying well
maybe that could get a little busted and
I'm like but that's kind of the whole
goal it's like and at least like the
raid you can still get a piece of radar
meter drop and it could have like a
crappy roll and you might be still in
the mid-50s and I can go get a random
roll or something else that might be
higher and somewhere else so it's like I
think the minimum stats in the raid
probably should be higher for one I
think that to at least give you rewards
of like hey if I go do the raid I'm
gonna do this pain in the butt thing at
least I know the stats on this armor if
I do get a piece of armor are gonna be
top - your stats it should be like mid
60's are almost like maybe Cap'n at 70
give it a different range that gives you
an advantage to go for it we do have
challenge modes so that could come and
then keep in mind the raid is currently
I believe the only way to get from 950
to 960 so it kind of helps you get
busted in a different way yeah separate
that light like that obviously does help
crucible and stuff right well a little
bit an iron banner actually but in
regular crucible it doesn't really help
you in terms of wing stats and builds
and stuff so I definitely see what
you're saying but I mean there is that
other aspect where it is kind of helping
you become more powerful just in a I
guess where I'm going with it and I
don't know I think he may be with me on
this one is sense that like I miss the
days when we rated and you know the
people like you know Scout you guys you
guys complete it right but you guys are
the ones that knock this thing out you
come back to the common folk like
alright we're gonna carry you through
these weapons that really assist and we
integrate with Eli it kind of makes you
a little Opie because you put in the
time investment you put in the work you
got the drop and now I think it should
give you a significant advantage
encounter to encounter based on whatever
it is or at least that wise make you
feel you know it make you feel strong
you know I'm saying and I'm not saying
this this does help towards your overall
power yes but does it like I kind of
like when you know something makes you a
little bit o P in a certain section of
the Ray because it's like yo you put it
in the work you put in the world you you
know you you don't you know you did it
so that I guess that's that's where I'm
what I just was wishing that a little
bit more I get is it terrible waiters
now no this is just like a nitpick this
is not like oh my god this straight is
terrible because of this no no just
something I want to see if they they may
not ever go back to it you don't saying
this may be kind of where they're at
you know them saying as far as it and at
the very least you know for me I'm
definitely would eat that though those
stats should be a little higher and
obviously you know we have the little
extra mod slot in the arm armor for I'm
assuming these were rate specific one
great logo yeah I guess either I got the
tether on when I went through so it's
actually one thing that I'm that's weird
for me about the armor 2.0 system and
especially like mods being permanent is
like you know it was kind of an
objective every week when you're doing
last wish like oh I have to get both
secret chests like I have to I have to
try to get taking invigoration or take a
barrier or any of these things with it
with the new system it's like you get it
once and you have it you know after you
get all six of the mods that are
transition baby let's get it let's talk
about it hey let's talk about it sour
4.0 scale you're on to what my long-term
fear is continue please so after you get
all six of these mods in this new raid
it's like you never have to open the
secret chests again and I also have this
theory forming with the secret chests I
have never threw out all of my raids
none of my fire team members have ever
gotten a piece from a piece of armour
from those chests that they didn't
already own so I think the side chest
sorry Mike I keeps jumping on my lammie
okay fine
I feel like their secret chest so you
can't get armor that you don't already
have so I feel like they're they're
quickly becoming obsolete and you won't
have to get that secret chests now
granted with the mod thing and that'll
kind of herd the replayability of the
raid especially the mod thing I one
thing with the mod thing that's kind of
nice is you can go back like I don't
know if you guys are aware of this I'm
sure you are but maybe not even all of
the Year one rayar all the year two
raids that
have special things to like the hive
invigoration that taken yeah yeah yeah
you can go get permanent versions of
them yes
so that's cool it gives it so it's kind
of like a catch-22 or yeah that's the
phrase it's kind of weird because it's
less reason to play this right over and
over again but at the same time now you
have three other reads every yeah three
other reasoning we do for mods right yes
Kranz so that's I feel like Bungie is
taking the approach of hey we're taking
some content away season season by
season but we want you to have reasons
to go play things that are staying in
the game that we obviously dedicated a
lot of time to you
I really appreciate that I think I think
it's it will definitely hurt the
replayability at least kind of for
players who aren't essentially like
let's beef up our raid report stats
right like yeah you're not like that
once you get all the mods and all the
weapons and all the armor I don't really
see many reasons to be incentive yeah
yeah yeah leading into something there
so yeah let's get to point O and I'm
saying it's I don't know we've been you
know now sitting around with it I think
um you know I have a lot to say about it
obviously but I think now that with
Connor you give it your pass off
Caribbean you now 50s or wherever you're
at and now you're tweaking right now
you're getting your energy levels up
you're moving things around you're
unlocking more stuff and first thing for
me I'll say is I do enjoy 2.0 I I'm
having a lot of fun you know I'm saying
I'm making things that synergize with
bills you know I'm saying
um having a ton of fun and that
obviously there's a couple of ones I'm
still missing I'm like damn where's my
you know light reactor or whatever it is
you know super action going or I got the
pump-action one just now so I'm happy so
I got shotgun energy one and it's just
quick interjection did you see that
dusty says outdated so you can mm-hmm
you just cut out right there he's just
[Music]
account or the website made by I believe
Josh hunt updated it for a beta version
today that actually tracks which mods
you have like if you're you know if you
want white reactor you you can make sure
you don't have it and you're just not
checking the wrong element or something
yeah thank God for it because it's like
yeah cuz shout out PhotoShelter Tassie
got a great are now in reference to that
because that's my only complaint you i
waz it's like please let me know what
mod i just like got this marble we spent
10 minutes which yeah which law which
energy type i guess we did to like dylan
Cosmo was just like hey can we get a
collection in here in a you so we can
actually see what we have what they
attach to what sources are really
obsolete like yeah do these enhanced
like we just like reactor just come from
tower engrams or you're like where did
where did we get these that's what I was
like my biggest question right now is
I'm a big black armory guy right I still
go in there a lot and I'm noticing when
I'm getting black armory armor 2.0
there's a black armory mod nom yes I'm
assuming you get it in that activity but
like it would be nice to know if there's
other sources or whatever you know just
you need the sources and the thing that
kills me is that when you get an exotic
or any other weapon in the game in
collections they show you the last seven
things that you got so it's like why
couldn't the mod money there's like this
is the perfect spot but really that's
just me playing I've know it to you I
think I'll probably get on it and knock
it out at the end of the day shoutout to
nether yeah I'm loving the black army
stuff - you haven't get my stuff back
2.0 version but um yeah man I think for
me overall I think I do like it I I love
messing with the combinations I'm
getting into some bills I'm not gonna
say they broke it but I'm having a lot
of fun with some synergies you know I'm
saying I got me like a Monte Carlo with
my solo warlock class I'm doing armed
son bracers I'm getting the melee back
I'm just like constantly getting like
son braces ready all the time somebody
get back bold slap and I'm getting
paradigm I'm doing a lot of flows with
it so it is cool um I don't know what
yeah if you are aware there's a
seriously broken build right now what
hunter blade barrage I know if you guys
know about yeah tell them what what
there tell them what tell them what they
won Johnny Five Year what they've won is
a combination of you your to basically
mix and I forgot the specific flow but
all in all you're getting braver Roger
what is it like 15-20 seconds yeah it's
it's discussed so some people holding
onto some year one stuff and what a
right mix of year two and then they're
getting that for hunter so shout out to
hump tears you better take advantage as
much as you can because it's lit out yet
but overall that's where I'm at but back
to you guys
what plan on that I really like that
we're talk now is I have that I don't
know if you guys saw like I curated like
the perfect Titan build where you add
your shoulder charge back every three
seconds with her grind Greaves and ones
you push yeah you were one shotting
every loss sector so I made the decision
of advertising it and then putting a
video and I was like this is all I'm
taking into the raid and then the very
next day Bungie was like actually yeah
turn that off real fast about a Spencer
the toaster toaster we're both off
pretty quick yeah mmm shut up real quick
two little purple by the way all cuz you
came in here she's dropping some
dropping some donations and chat so
thank you very much
seriously thank you very much for those
anyways back to it but I just I love
that we are in because I've always been
of the of the mind like this is this
might be kind of sacrilege but I never
played you know World of Warcraft I I
never played the division I remember
last time I was on here it's actually
talking like I might download for the
beta and then I got busy with something
else like neither but I was I've never
been previous to this like a big build
guy like in destiny I never really paid
attention to a lot of my armor purchase
like why haven't perks are really
important but past
perks I could care less about like I
could've bless about I guess and then
Armour to point I'll wash and then just
something clicked in my head where I was
just like oh oh my goodness why ever not
why have I not been doing this the whole
time right and it's like you I think
Armour to point out what it did has made
this whole build mentality very
accessible and not only accessible like
very appealing yeah and I love it I saw
I turned from a guy who's like I I never
paid attention to my intellect
discipline strength and destiny wanna my
mobility recovery or resilience to
destiny to do a guy who's like now
trying to max out every possible stat
that I could want for my specific builds
if I had its it's weird how they can add
so many more stats in the game and it
feels like it should be overwhelming but
at the end of the day it's just kind of
renewed my curiosity and interest and if
anything like made the whole system make
more sense to me yeah absolutely so ya
know I'm loving it I armor 2.0 I think a
with the mod thing there's some there's
some longevity things there especially
great stuff but in terms of like giving
you unlimited ways to play I mean we
went from my kind of a big gripe I used
to have was like you people always ask
for like the original destiny once
skills cruise back right and I was
always like why like there's one good
willed maybe two per one of those trees
like there's ninety percent those perks
are useless and I feel like instead of
expanding on the skill trees and doing
that this was their way of kind of like
tuning play styles and I think this
worked so well so very one my I think my
biggest gripe with it is like you know
now obviously I have to go back and
grind so I have like a last wish armor
set or I guess like take and armor set a
high arm set a phone one I'm now at next
one and I think like I wish there was
some way in game to be like I want my
backs armor set on so I didn't have my
search through all my different loadouts
if I find like an updated piece that I
want then I have to go back in and alter
it and dim and that's where stuff I wish
there's a way in destiny just to be like
alright
all right how even it like I know this
is kind of odd whatever you might get
hit enter for its last leg vex loadout
or something everything on sick that be
sick
I think we're taking I'm asking for kind
of too much too soon I think we're very
much going in the the most right
correction that we could possibly be
have no doubt man II we're yeah I'm
curious you are the person who is
generally the most critical when it
comes to Alma very curious to play you
know mid maxing or whatever the hell
you've been doing what is your man where
you add I'm very curious so as more and
more mods start to unlock I'm kind of
doing the same thing like hey I got
machine gun reserves finally you can put
two of those on the same piece the same
piece of chest armor it's like you can
actually kind of max out certain things
and definitely the same thing looking
for stats or like normally like some
rolls and they're not all good rolls
right now but I'm like hey there's a
roll that's like 22 male am like maybe
I'll hold on to that in case I want to
go a melee builders like they those are
the things you look at if one stat is
just like BAM and you're like oh that
might be good for something I'm like I
need to go through and get rid of some
of my like average rolls but something
like way heavy one way or the other
mm-hmm those are definitely a certain
things I'm starting to look forward to
but Oh caveat the cost to take this
armor to the og 10 so you can't actually
really start tweaking your build
oh yeah so like this is so like this
I'll just dive into this one because
this has been what I've been thinking
about doing more and more math get it so
if you want to farm the ascendant shards
yeah you're only gonna be able to get
those in basically like the 980
nightfalls so you're gonna have to be
either plus 30 bonus if you're not doing
pinnacles which is gonna take some time
because that it's it's exponentially it
grows that yeah it grows so it's gonna
be a while cuz I'm at like 9 I think
I've heard people at 10 11 12 13 not
like nobodies like plus 20 yet so the
1980s while they're doable and you get
closer but the big thing
for me is it takes if you want to go buy
it from banshee you're like hey I've
been farming some materials hey how
close am I one ascendant shard is gonna
cost you a hundred Enhancement course
one hundred thousand glimmer two hundred
and fifty planetary materials Wow yeah
yeah and then on top of that 100 100
more planet materials 50,000 more
glimmer and yeah so it's basically you
better love this thing that you're gonna
map yeah it's like and I think that's
one of the things like maybe when we get
to higher like 980 s and those things
you can just like hey I need some
ascendant shards or whatever to take
this thing to ten I can go grind out
some 980 night falls you know run three
of them and master work to send em hmm
and that's fine not everybody's gonna be
able to solo those those do not have
matchmaking in them which some people
are getting used to and then they're
gonna be like 950 oh crap I can't do
this by myself anymore and it's the
price that's gonna take to really dive
deep into these like mod setups cause
like if you're like hey I got this
really good start roll cool what if you
get a piece of armand that drops and
it's like one more like it's almost the
same stat roll like your current build
same energy affinity and then on top of
that it's like hey this thing dropped
with like two or three more stats from
the raid than the one I have but I just
dumped like my entire life Peggy Bay
into this one piece of armors like do i
do I am I really gonna go for those
stats anymore and I think that's gonna
be one of the things that is almost a
bigger drawback for me is the cost of
really upgrading things cuz you can take
it to about seven and like I've got
enough cores I've been hoarding I mean
you know I keep doing getting bounties
and stuff for everything so I'm like I'm
doing okay on course but like right now
it would take me I could basically
master work seven pieces of armor and I
would be broke
yes and that's that set that's one full
set and then two additional pieces
that's it I would be living that one
dream but if I want to change that dream
I'm screwed like I think honestly I got
to cut you that I think that's what they
want though I think they they are tired
of us hoarding let's be who is this they
you speak up yeah we
or guilty as charged as hardcore destiny
players we have a tendency to have an
overabundance of materials and they have
to figure out a way to kind of curb us
and I think and again I'm a play
developer now I got my Bungie hat on but
it's like at the end of the day you know
when your tier tinning something right
let's think about what that means right
we are literally probably 2 to 3
extremely powerful perk combinations of
my combinations that are gonna be on
this one set be pretty strong cuz prior
to that you probably could only have
about 2 or 3 and I'm saying like now
you're getting into a different type of
a territory these things could be you
know very strong so I think this is
their way because even if even if even
the way they've separated certain perks
before you know I'm saying that we used
to have our little bills you know I'm
saying your reload is your scavenger on
one you're a super energy that's on that
like they've separated a lot of that
stuff by energy affinity to so certain
combinations care you over together
so I've seen like their master plan is
we got a slow yard down just a little
bit so if you want to go all the way out
you gonna have to commit they what they
want you to put a ring on and eat you
you love that on what you want to do
that put a ring on it get better send it
thing but you're gonna be broke fade it
off okay so here's the King like see if
you want to run machine guns and fusions
those don't go together because machine
guns are our confusions or solar yeah so
in theory you need three sets either way
if you want to mix things up so that's
15 pieces of armor so take whatever I
just told you for those cores multiply
that by 15 that sounds like too much for
even the three of us so guess what you
gonna stay you're behind you very
curious when it comes to like when we
get to 980 how many like you know
grinding out that nightfall you're gonna
go through and grind that nightfall like
ten times would be like hey I got those
cores that's gonna be one of those
things because yeah that's I think we're
gonna be the biggest sources like they
wanted to give that nightfall a purpose
and that nine
is the only place to get those things
they don't grow up in raids maybe the
dungeon we don't know yet but that's
literally the one place for those things
and it's like for you it's a very
specific place to upgrade I mean what
about crucible people there what if they
don't want to go run night falls they're
not ever gonna max out their armor and
be able to run the mod combination they
want to so then you you get into places
where like the cost of those at people
like hey I do my Banshee bounties I'm
saving up course you're talking we have
to get 1500 cores just to max out three
des that's like no no average player is
gonna be like holy mother of what holy
mother chicken is what I was gonna say
because that was that was the fitting
phrase those like I can't cuss right now
but what about this suggestion what
about bonus to you guys in reference to
may be making those pinnacle rewards
with armors that have those energy slots
unlocked or maybe like once in a while
so yeah maybe like an option to do that
I are you kind of like how rare it is
like hey I'm torn right like I I'm the
type of person that's I grind for
everything right like obviously that is
like I I am the guy who you give me
something to chase I'll chase it I'll
chase it for days Weezer's and so the
armor sets kind of like like that like
oh I want to work towards it and get
full armor sets but then once I've hit
it it's like what do I grind for now I
like having the space it's kind of wait
I don't know how I feel about it to be
honest it's like how often will you
actually need all ten of those slots I
found that I can get away with what can
you get without those rods I think you
can get six or seven because my another
prisms and tin so it's like ya know I
found um I found that with just seven
you can do like pretty much everything
unless you want to have like to enhance
perks which I don't even have though
like enough of those yet for that even
so I see what you're saying yeah I don't
know I I mean vent talk to me in three
months well yeah when we're all
get it out and I might be like this is
imbalanced we also I mean I keep saying
it but the Rey challenges could bring
these like that's that's harder than the
raid maybe they'll give us an ascendant
shards the the prisms I think you call
them hmm maybe that I don't know
yeah I'm way Procrit professor kate
Kaioken you said I do DC I didn't think
it makes sense that if you can do
high-level cut you have better gear
access not saying crucible should be
worse than nightfall but maybe I should
drop better gear from competitive since
it's more challenging yeah I mean I'm
with that in this sense like I said it
will be cool if they can come up with a
way you know like I said if you do on
Pinnacle activities that yo maybe it
drops already at a tier 8 or tier you
know I'm saying whatever the slight
energy slot is already so that you know
you don't necessarily have to utilize
what is it that thing was a prism as a
cold I forgot that the the new currency
that they want you to maximize but um
yeah I mean that's my idea but honestly
you know like Scott saying I'm not this
is just me nitpicking I really enjoy the
system you know um I think the other
point I want to make was just that it
takes me back now like every drop has
value I'm looking at you know every
legendary now hold on you got a lot you
got a intellect and a resilience yeah
okay I gotta keep you because I want my
super or whatever to build is I'm
keeping certain things because I'm like
you know this could work let me hold on
to you you are really peaking at a
certain level right right II you you you
kind of see things I've never used to
look at armor like that everything is up
shard shark shark here's another
legendary Char Char Char okay I'm not
doing that no more like at least with
armor I am you being at those stats yeah
I'm looking at what it affects in
reference to my subclass and in
reference to what I am doing with said
subclass so yeah this is I feel sorry
for your vote because I know how you
horrid it prior to 2.0 yeah so now you
bust you gonna be a mess I like well
that we've been playing so much and
picking stuff up ahead damn on like art
of auto farm mode and I go through him
like crap I got blues I gotta clean out
and I'm like well some of these could be
good so I need to go through its like at
least it's 60s I probably need to be
keeping them but even if it's high 50s
and it's got a pretty heavy stat roll it
might keep it
it's just and then I'm going like okay
our solar void decent rolls like there's
a lot just math wise to go to your head
you're like arc solar void 20 stats here
this thing does this bender and it's
like one slot you're like it just you
know the hangover math see and always
appears in your head so but I would like
I mean that's another thing as you guys
said as well that I think would be
another thing that I there might be a
missed opportunity or something they can
add later do harder content and have it
drop gear that drops at like six energy
seven energy eight energy nine energy
like some crazy stuff like that would be
ways to say hey the rate doesn't have
you know crazy higher stats but it drops
at like eight or nine energy yes and
that would give you a way to make it
worth you know worth that guy he's like
dude I can save myself some currency by
going to run the raid and that's that's
very expensive like that would that
would again give a different incentive
without breaking you know too powerful
just give you incentive in a different
way and I think that might be something
but yeah that's that's actually really I
think that's the way maybe yeah maybe
not I have it maybe I don't like a one
in 75 chance or something that's fully
unlocked yeah but I do like the idea
that cuz I don't think I've seen
anything drop higher than six if I've
seen five like I don't see yeah I know
yeah
what can drop I think I like that would
be a nice thing just to know like okay
so what in the hell can we like put
together for you know where what's the
dungeon gonna have in it I know we've
got some weapons that are gonna come
from there so does not exclusive call
about the dungeon yo that's my baby I'm
still waiting no I don't love that
somebody tweeted out me like are you
gonna go into the back in the shadow
third when you hit 999 I'm like of
course I am
but that's like hahaha but no like the
dungeon again it's like if that's just
dropping you know sixty one stats with
like basic stuff it's like your
incentive again that's where like that's
where some of these more pinnacle things
like if it says pinnacle reward that's
natural should be freaking amazing like
reach average like Todd's your stats
like higher energy role like oh you're
in this badass encounter you should
probably be rewarded for in different
ways
maybe we're not gonna give you an eight
East at roll so if
you master can put them on and give like
102 stats that might be a little broken
but like maybe the intervention that's
one thing I was sitting there somebody
was going through doing the math and I
was like I'd like to see a little higher
stats but if you put a mod on it you get
+10 and then if you master work you get
plus 12 so if you have something out
like if you got something to drop it
like 78 and you did those two things
that literally have a hundred stats I'm
like yeah yeah so like that maybe why
the gap is where it is but that's also
why like it is also a bummer if you I
need to break him down but your old
armor exotics they've like I have a pair
of boots with like 23 stats and it's
like my old exotic Luna factions they
had like no stat role of 23 I was like
oh my god they're awful I'm not even
like even if they have different decent
perks of like both like sniper perks I'm
like the stats are off over there cuz I
started to look at that I'm like
screaming I got some cool mods and
someone that you know my old armor put
1.0 and I'm like wait a minute
why is it completely missing mobility in
the disciplines that are starting stuff
yeah cuz you rush you once you get a
gray shading in 2.0 and you start
messing around you start to see how the
armor 1.0 stuff really doesn't hold any
more weight I mean hasslein you can't
even use the artifact stuff anymore so
really you're missing out on that big
stuff not on an extra stuff and I was
like I'm I don't know how many times you
can reset the thing to how expensive it
gets
I don't know if anybody's done the math
on that yet I know it's ten thousand but
I'm like debating on the perks I'm like
all worried I'm like I just need to pick
something and use them because I want to
do that's not like on the fourth column
the top in the middle the deal with the
grenades that do disruption the grenade
is you get grenade energy from barrier
kills and then the void one that weakens
the enemies like that's like gonna be
one build probably I can't refigure
figure out which character and then the
melee one for arc might be another
character I'm just trying to figure out
which one wants to go where but now I'm
looking forward to doing that so really
they're just like kind of casually
shoving you off the 2.0 cliff and be
like yo that's what you want to down
there just just leave the old stuff at
the top of the highway I agree forceful
transition so have you guys had any fun
you've done recently or anything you
guys are messing with or or or other
things in your mind where you're like I
don't have it all together yet but I
think I can't get there I'm just trying
to keep my recluse relevant I think you
passed my goat you pass my go figure my
go figure had like 40 someone 47,000
kills too so man that's the thing like
going back to like doodoo rates have
good weapons and stuff honestly I hope
they don't have good energy ones because
we're like I just got it bro I literally
got recluse really like it's never
leaving that slot I now I get it I might
just keep in mind did you just get it
this season I literally just got it I
got it
two days ago a tweet it's it's not even
as good as it used to be that's what I
heard yeah it that master of arms oh my
lord like I got a build right now where
I'm using that and I'm using bottom tree
warlock with the flower so I'm just
praça master of all keeping that going
cracking the viola keep getting health
and it's just it's it's dirty babe it's
not like this is like wow yeah I got
somebody other build I got another I'm
using a storm caller bottom tree I've
dusted off vesper of radius oh that what
I'm using it in the rake cuz this is
what I digs I was so know that at first
when I heard the well of radiance nerves
so baby it's not gonna be as good and I
want to be offensive so I pick
stormcaller still but I was like let me
go Vespa it bro I am getting my riffs so
fast because that's one of the intrinsic
perk of multiple enemies next to you get
spawn rift then I've got if I pick up
orbs I get riff I got Paragon mods on
the new 2.0 you know say so I am getting
on a yo come on yeah and then I got ox
holes so I'm like yo who what Dark Souls
come on cuz they're next to me and they
were just I'm making rift upon riff de
Palmer and people will love it when I'm
riding with the mid grade you know say
cuz again it's faster than having to
build up my whole super for example for
a well of radius so I'm just dropping
these little mini rifts I was doing that
a lot during the whole encounter where
we're facing the guy that
the box install right I'm like yo gay
cuz you know when you get it in the
minotaur spawn out as soon as you kind
of get the box in the raid deform the
thing so um yeah I've been doing that
for a lot of my teammates and I've been
helping them nice what about you scare
uh what do you got uh so I'm boring when
it comes to this stuff I find one thing
that works and I I just don't
so my goats here right now is really
boring and it's it's weird because I'm
not a huge warlock guy but because
warlocks are so potent in the final
encounter of the raid that's been kind
of like what I'm on most honestly
warlock recluse isn't all ye swarm
nothing special there I'm so jealous you
guys just well and weirdest is so it's
so powerful a wounded of factions not
you help me out cuz there's the nerf I'm
gonna be honest I've as you see history
loads I'm yeah I'm I was scared to put
it back on so is it really still helping
you like you really yeah yeah so the way
I do isn't on use is so one thing you
got to learn about me is I'm I'm kind of
a spaz like if I can be efficient in any
way I am going to be efficient in that
way right and so izanagi's is already
it's gonna reload especially if you
sprint cancel halfway through guys you
can hold are when you shoot so if you
never take your finger off are and you
shoot isn't Auggie's it will
automatically always compact your
bullets in the wood huh when honed yeah
you can hold off the rip okay exactly
I played kind of claw and sprint have as
soon as I see that one bullet sprint
shoot and weird if action makes that so
you can reload I mean so fast this may
be like way more seconds it's so fast
it's like if you put out on the mida
multi-tool that's how fast it is yeah
you're getting nose on honed edge
exactly exactly so Wow my strategy is
yeah I pretty much just sit there
yeah exactly and it's it's super nice on
Titan once again super boring my
actually that's probably my most unique
one that's the the build I made the
always infinite shoulder charge one hit
everything build you is in the raid I
run that but I do a shield bash Titan
instead of Tom Jerry hammers because the
void disorienting grenade pops is so
powerful and then on hunter I mean I
don't think anyone at this point could
pay me to ever get off middle tree arc
strider it's just it's probably the best
ad clearing super in the game it's
incredibly powerful our radiant flux is
still incredible that's pretty much
where I'm at although in crucible top
tree Golden Gun actually go the twelve
Guardians later you're like yeah I I'm
incredibly boring in the sense that I
never touched stormcaller
I barely ever touched voidwalker I never
touched its Heather honestly hanging out
again for other people too bro the only
Titan and that's just because Stryker is
so broken and crucible if it wasn't like
that I I would never touch Stryker
either what you running uh so the one
that I want to do I just need to
actually unlock the thing and I finally
just did I think I got the twelfth one
today so I want to go titan word of dawn
with the I think somebody in chat said
it's the oppressive darkness so
literally I can buff myself and debuff
the enemy with the void grenade the
weakens the enemy and I can buff me for
35% so I pop a bubble throw the grenade
and I'm buff 2d buffed with one person
so everybody else can just go nuts like
that's what I think is gonna be one that
I definitely want to get get my hands on
for that one so that's what I want to do
because I mean weapons the light is
definitely powerful now yeah I'll take
35 seconds said if you get that like a
well as you were doing like four
the third encounter one person have the
you know have the big buff take it with
you as you walk in then you know on the
second part once you guys are far enough
in the wall and still doing damage
papapapa well on the other side get more
damage that way so now it's like it's a
pretty cool thing and just the fact the
the grenades doing more and impairing
that with the grenades that will just
like pair with disruption and all of
those things is actually a pretty cool
build so yeah that first and third on
the fourth column in that second one on
the fifth is definitely what I'm gonna
have fun with on my tight and I've been
like my warlocks like my higher one and
that I kind of got my Titan up there
I've been like going back and forth
between those two my Titan or my hunter
hasn't even started the story yet so I
got a I got to get on that one so we've
talked about armor 2.0 it has its ups
and downs longevity we will see but
there's another piece when it comes to
vex offensive itself and the vex
invasions has all that stuff jumped in
have you guys been feeling about that
like first let's talk about the moon
like how do you guys feel like cuz my
big thing with the moon I was like hey I
didn't make my public event video like
how to turn everything to heroic because
I sold cocky no last time I was like
yeah I want to see what the new moon
public events gonna be it wasn't there
wasn't a new moon public event this is
like public event 2.0 so yes definitely
got a change so it gives it some nice
life what do you guys think about it
yeah I mean I'll jump off I mean I like
it I like I like a vex if I mean the
whole coming down and then you know
setting the thing off to proc first the
public event thing and I'm saying when
you look up in the sky for it
aesthetically it looks cool oh it like
so good it looks beautiful
I don't know if you guys I will just
look up at it like the black garden yeah
it's it's fertilizer yeah that's fire so
um yeah I like aesthetically that was
cool just to kind of get that going and
then to set off the actual offensive by
doing those activities was really cool I
like vex offensive I mean is it like the
most complex thing no you know saying
but I think aesthetically looks great
the play space is huge I like how that
big it feels so you're saying moving
around the balls chase you moving around
you got your little mechanic taking the
shield down or whatever whatever um I
like it you know is it
would still have menagerie over it
that's just me personally because I like
college talking his top well I'll do it
I'll do it you put like so you got
escalation blind well yeah oh definitely
at the bottom so I would say okay that's
easy
yeah bottom I still menagerie holds a
special place for me because not only is
it cool not only is their Lord not only
is Callas narrating your life you also
like it's just like thematically it's
just dope I just love it that escalation
was my jam don't like escalation was my
jam so it's it's cold I'm trying to
figure it's probably fighting for to wit
escalation I got to run it a little bit
more because we don't we have offensives
coming right we got my offensive with
the undying mind ROG it's just kind of
like Joe to help you inch escalation you
were lucky if you got one weapon every
like seven runs oh my god guys with whip
Beck's offensive I feel like I could be
completely wrong but it feels like me
you get three guaranteed weapons and
three guaranteed armor pieces every
single time you run I got a lot of crap
like I don't know those get lapis if
eclis but it's like yeah three four five
six drops of something yeah I mean once
again not like super unique perks but a
lot of them have like really good perks
yeah so not vex offensive is lit man I
mean it's rewarding for the time
investment it's fun like that's just get
it out the way it has matchmaking which
obviously over escalator I suppose you
still hold a thing for me I don't know
what it is about it why I don't like the
bus roll yeah like the way you don't
have to fight to have a fireteam right
no you got something that kill you right
yeah I automatically I'm being fair I
got a subtract one I'm gonna handle it
I gotta take those two subtract you saw
my game protocol was just like its own
activity and they made like literally
another zone that was like here's the
bottom part of Mars
go play solution protocol in that yeah
then why did I think I figured it out
the reason why I still fight with why I
love it so much is let's be real y'all
how did you feel when you first got
escalation protocol shiny baby
well you got trench back cool when you
first get how long it took to drop you
was feeling yourself he's feeling good
when you got that I just want to see if
vex has something you know that makes
you go okay you don't say like I want to
grind for this like it's like yay shower
you got it it's fun you're grinding for
is that undying seal yeah basically and
I don't know if it's gonna be like it's
not gonna be the hardest one to get
hopefully but it's like you know just
the fact that you can have your
character's name and is undying be like
I don't think they made it very
difficult because it's like essentially
time gated right like offensive is being
heated at the end of this season so if
you don't grind out and get this now I'd
be able to get it so I think they had to
make it kind of easy easier I mean
that's it that's another thing that puts
a vex offensive like kind of helps it at
least in my mind get closer if not
surpass Menagerie is the most annoying
thing about Menagerie was the the
flawless run so I don't know if you are
you guys do seal no I do not I'm so
happy
especially hasta pico the the giant
hydra hydra what's the most annoying
thing is when getting all six people
through that without dying without dying
i sing for the best offensive the not
dying triumph is you and you alone
require you I team can die as long as
you're not bad hell yeah
that's not so bad I saw that time gated
and that sort of thing I think I in my
mind the way it works is like if I'm
just looking at the menagerie in Bexar
fence again not sure how it is now I
believe where you only get one drop
bottom that's offensive and the
menagerie the original where you could
get seven or eight drops that's gonna be
above we know scatter loves his reward
got that efficiency mindset their
efficacy what's time investment equaling
[Laughter]
the e rankings hmm yeah I was like I
don't think blind Wells gonna be very
high I want to put it on like okay so
blind well fam no Tier four blind well
okay I will say Tier four blind well
actually had some decent light decency
to like tear-filled one bad for those
little bosses like it was funny how
quickly everybody got used to melting
the meatball though the meatball oh my
god you're like yes instant death cool
that was actually yeah but yeah we're
not gonna rank at the reckoning that's
obviously the top right dude people can
farm that they wait for a heavyweight
yeah The Reckoning yeah my spare
Russians like people probably hate me
for mine cuz it's pretty much a god role
and I tripped over and so they did
basically so for me yeah I'd say like
fine reckoning it and blind well are
near the bottom even I like I think the
menagerie paired with the chalice still
has something kind of unique to it yeah
when the rewards were good but I also
like the idea win the rewards you could
roll different things I don't I mean
yeah getting five hand cannons when it
was like this last like the last week or
last week of year - yeah you could get
like five hand cans to be like cool I'm
gonna just basically be parting all
these things yeah so that was one thing
when you go through and like run out run
back it's like it'd be nice if that's
what like so many people had different
ideas when you listen to multiple
podcasts and different things they're
like hey have three chests if you do an
encounter perfectly toss aforethought on
there you could go through and have your
200 seconds be like open this one for
this okay let me ruin this thing yeah
open this one for this like I don't know
why that wouldn't be such a bad thing to
be like then you go for different things
I don't need 14 different hand cannons
that all potentially suck so menagerie
is and I also like the uniqueness to the
encounters we're like you didn't always
get the same run you could do two runs
and be doing something different so Labe
the menagerie for me is like probably
still one of the best activities I think
they've done with giant caveat on the
end of it what status the rewards are in
the rewards right if you're gonna spin
like I was like especially the way the
mechs offensive is just like showering
you with stuff right now
like vets effects was like here here
here here please forget that we did this
back here like they're throwing this
stuff at you but win when menagerie was
good I actually really did enjoy it
because you got variety in the encounter
you didn't always see the same thing
different bosses every week because
we're not getting a new boss so far it's
still just the big moments are the same
unless it changes on Saturday which
would be weird but I like the variety of
that versus you know what we had what we
have now is is decent so I'd say
menagerie probably top in the right
state as the caveat but if like rewards
as is right now the showering the
looting the VEX offensive is it's a fun
cool activity not to Jenny
what one more point to give Menagerie
the title you can literally chalice farm
whatever your week at currently with
banaji right now so if you're looking at
your loadout and you're like yo my legs
are weak or hey my energy weapon you can
theoretically specifically farm some
even if you don't care about the drop
you know i'm saying oh you're just
trying to hit that light level yeah
there you go see that's what I like
about menagerie I mean don't wise for
like it just use a wisely for the recent
powerful drops anymore are they let
legendary drops I'm like you mean old
school stuff school chicken stuff I want
to see where in finish to offense
offense but we just I want to see also
where it goes that's all but yes it's
mad fart like the only I'm not dislike I
love I enjoyed it I was really having a
good time and again enough matchmaking
you jump in you jump out just showering
your stuff and it was just I just love
to play space and I love not just the
rewards it was really cool yeah
so speaking of vex and the offensive and
the invasions have you guys seen what's
going on in the tower behind decora
yeah I used to work for construction
company and see how this thing safety is
not a priority really at the tower boy
how're the dude is just sitting out
there on the rafters man he just sneezes
the wrong direction he's got like okay
you know our enemy let's have a portal
right to them yeah we're gonna like go
to the tower and it's gonna turn into a
play space where you fight for your
lives or something gonna be zero our 2.0
load from the red wall we bring them to
the doors no we not learned from the red
we like gave them the ability to
expedite the read you guys can just warp
right in I color I already reach it with
your nose these portals are Bert that's
not close enough let's bring them to us
baby hyper jump ships be like just worst
case scenario the Vexin invade earth
we'll just have Calais use the live
eiffel earth evacuation basically
everybody in this tower that's the only
people left everybody get on your ships
go and I think everyone in the top the
the first to die I think the farms the
only place right the undying mind comes
through that portal towers gone yes even
though even though I will say if you
were saying in that picture with them in
the cinematic with shacks and he sees
access and he's still alive I'm pretty
sure shacks
I'm pretty sure Sal know it Saladin just
really like he's got you know endurance
his endurance Ned years to Train his
heart muscle is just like beat it was
like that sets up so I was like I like
so every week it's like take your screen
shot kind of do a time-lapse see what it
looks like yeah that you guys an amazing
representation of this living world that
we was talking about though the fact
that he just kind of like popped up yep
that if you I mean in destiny one
nothing like that without that what
happened this is it's honestly
incredible and the fact that it's
probably going to something's gonna
happen and it probably won't be there
next season or it'll only be like
aesthetic next season that's really cool
as well where we're getting these how
about the fact that she's building a new
platform before the original towers even
like this though right so that's a weird
thanks completely agree man he's just
and I get my phone back please
I got a galley I gotta go I don't know
if you guys know that's like I've God in
a gun so I need to find
yes yeah this is that again like what
look like said man that narrative
continent continuity which is what we
want you know I'm saying it feels like a
living breathing world those moments
like he said when you're at the tower
when such-and-such happen when you're
playing destiny wouldn't this hat like
that's going in the last point I'll make
is just I'll be honest like I got a feel
for Eris with this expansion like this
expansion made me feel for my Damji
chick is tormented man like you know you
go and you do the wheel for the second
memory this week boiler how every time
you complete a memory like one of the
ghosts disappeared disappeared table
next to where she like the artifacts
like you know you built the necklace and
the necklace appears on the table and
then you did the mark and it appears
beautiful beautiful it's like they take
the you know like how when we were
talking Mar tomorrow week after week yes
yes couldn't really tell what week you
were on like nothing everybody right
same thing with like the the memories of
the the gifts of the nine to the night
yes you could only like nothing physical
everything this is really it's like
world the building through very yelled a
bro I'm you could glad you mentioned a
point about her original fireteam and
then one disappears yeah it's time
that's such a subtle cool touch and
again it's the little things there again
I know people who are not destiny guys
who come time playing like oh you guys
if they lot of my own I whatever okay I
get it but it's like at the end of the
day there's so much world building and
things that we've been clamoring for as
destiny fans for the longest and to see
them do it that's what has me so excited
for shadow team and it makes you tune in
every day like now I get happy when you
see the direct it as I go this is
happening now
the nightmare huh it's gonna be this
okay bull facts offensive just probably
it's like little YouTube looks like tune
in next week when this happens it's like
a little show like I really enjoy it
really do I guess my question is when it
comes to first Aris like what happens on
week six when her fire team's gone are
we gonna do something for her is that
gonna kick something different off
trying to think too cuz that's gonna be
that's gonna be the raid challenge week
six a week would be mmm-hmm yeah I was
gonna I was wondering if I was actually
gonna tie in with the dungeon but that's
not quite right on weeks but yeah we've
still got so that's one thing I think
people give the moon a lot of crap but
seriously it's been redone yes I had
like nostalgic like yes I recognize the
Hellmouth I recognize the anchor of
light but is like you go through the
underbelly it's still one of the biggest
play spaces for because there's the hole
above ground and the subterranean is as
big if not bigger now with like Sara's
Harbor you've got literally two levels
to an entire place and it's like it's
probably the second biggest planet
except tdz in like full areas that you
can explore honestly biggest
disappointment is the fact that you
can't jump into the Hellmouth land it
circle of those I know I hate that
because you look I mean I totally agree
like they and they're just the little
details like tannic sketch being crashed
right you know the path to Curtis Temple
being kind of shaped a little bit
differently like as if the the cracking
of the moon really changed yet a little
bit and that sort of stuff like yeah I
think they did a really fantastic job
and they have the expanded plane area I
was like the war set and not anchor of
white the other one like the old
spawning literatures line with archers
line and the additional area out to the
side of the lost sector where like the
public event spawns and that sort of
stuff white they really flesh it out
like really really well that entire area
where eros is I mean didn't exist I see
one right like it's kind of an extra
little corner so many secrets and stuff
they did really well I don't know if you
guys saw I think jb3 on the raid secrets
right actually pointing this out I
believe in the tannic strike they're
using there was like a cheese spot where
there's like a servitor eye and you
would hide from tan X by like climbing
on top of like a computer if you go up
there there's actually like a crouching
shadow guy
just completely hit in a way like as
total really cool right yeah even I
would have to cut you work just the
little touches with the voices for
patrols
it's always the guy on archers line
who's like the one where you kill
enemies he's like there's too many of
them like what dude hold on calm down
such a nice touch man yeah that whole
haunted thing it really goes lining in
line with it such cool well that's again
like they did this with the dreaming
city but making patrols not feel just
like beacons like making them feel like
part of the world
brilliant yeah very good there world
building team I don't know if this is
like a new narrative director or someone
who's like just a new direction but I
mean they're killing it they are really
killing it with immersive world building
I think so very cool yeah absolutely so
speaking of the moon as well get a
little more on our nightmare hunts we've
seen a few more of these so we get this
week we've got gall we've got tan X and
we've got why am i forget in the third
one does it follow us right focus that's
the other one so for the nightmare
constantly difficulties what are you
guys thinking as these things escalate
and that kind of tie me into something
else but I won't know your thoughts on
the nightmares we've seen about six of
them so far haven't done I've done one
of them total I spam for the time trials
yet or is that later I don't know what I
know what you're talking about cuz
there's a triumph somewhere yeah I don't
know difficult is it met is it a higher
difficulty have to do them on hey it
doesn't say like it just says complete
complete the nightmares need to like
sprint I basically I wish if I knew I
could do it now I would knock them out
but no nightmare hunts are cool but I
just I would rather be doing back so
offensive I think like it's a cool
little touch but they were part of the
campaign for the most part I mean it's
an extra
as I look at it too I mean it's nothing
terrible anything it's just like I'm
just so I'm or I'm a bit scared I'm more
excited about other things yeah and I
look at it I might up it I gotta get a
powerful I'll go get it
I'll go do it but I'm not like going
back but there's some parts that I'm
like okay this is nostalgia you remember
what you would do in you remember when
you first encounter did ya a person
whatever whatever didn't give you some
feels but yes what I got eat I mean for
me it's like I'll be kind of curious to
see where the difficulties though but
that kind of ties more into the artifact
mods itself
what because as the difficulties
increased this time we got here--oh
so you have your the UNSTOPABLES you've
got your barriers things like that
roaming around those now more frequently
what do you guys think about I mean
obviously I know scary you love recluse
but if you take recluse out of the
picture for example Nominet okay no but
here's here's the reason it might what
if it was and this is why I kind of
wonder right now you've got hand cannons
auto rifles submachine guns and bows
basically that can use those unstoppable
barrier and mm-hmm what is the other mod
I'm trying to think of its those enemies
exist yet by the way what is the third
time have we seen him yeah well there's
a there's so if it's the VEX one is the
overload overload Minotaur that's the
Minotaur that's somewhere yes night
falls yeah so the barriers are always
the Knights typically there was those
Knights with the big topics you can be
disturbed yeah yes and then when it
comes to the overload I've seen overload
ogres so they're actually running around
this week I've seen a little bit and
also wait wait overload overload it's in
the nightfall you'll see it a couple
times if you run isn't that the Minotaur
II though uh no unstoppable I'm sorry
unstoppable ogres so the ogres are
unstoppable in its it's the hand cane on
the chaff to actually like aim down
sights
you'll get the sheen on the gun and then
that one bullet will stop him in his
place
okay yet to encounter any of those so if
you go run the nightfall it's the
Scarlet keep this week which I've run a
few times still
I don't know if there's an exclusive
weapon that comes from there but it
definitely doesn't know I believe it's
been confirmed that none of the two plus
the PlayStation exclusive I don't think
any of them exclusives unfortunately
well that's another topic but anyway
we've got like so as those are tied like
you've got hand cannons on barrier
unstoppable as the literally only thing
hand cannons is the only thing that can
run that so if your modifiers have to be
you know say you have unstoppable and
you've got I don't know barrier for what
it is this week so you have to run a
hand cannon to have be unstopped alike
to manage the non-stop right they have
the rel they're forcing you to and then
it's also hand cannon auto and machine
gun or an tank an auto and submachine
gun so you've got relatively on the
range spectrum you're on the shorter end
of that stick for sure no pulses there's
no Scouts there's no snipers fusions
there's none of that other stuff in
there much less specials by any means
right and even the new sniper hand
cannon is still high in cannon so all of
those things I'm wondering as they tie
deeply into the nightmare hunts and then
you've also got you know vex offensive
having UNSTOPABLES and stuff in there do
you guys what do you see next seasons
artifacts doing because the nightmares
because we've got night falls that have
UNSTOPABLES in there we've got
nightmares that we think are staying
around mm-hmm and the vex offensive is
leaving is it always gonna be barrier
unstoppable and overload or do you guys
think they're gonna mix those up a
little bit more I think they'll keep the
same three but they'll switch the
archetypes I'm thinking one so maybe you
like shotgun sniper or something else
you know yeah I think so I think this is
the new direction they're going
especially as we have things like
recluse effe
again I think they want to get us to
utilize different archetypes and
different things and to force these
special mods to be used on these least
used weapons so to speak you know I'm
saying I think that's the vibe because
let's be honest we're not really I'm not
I'm not really running around PvE with
hand cannons as much these days and
right we kind of get in our way I'm
gonna say anyway we scare us like for me
it's like Izanami
then it's it's recluse and then you know
for me I don't have to swarm
so it's outrageous fortune you're gonna
say but like I'm kind of like it's hard
to move me off of that right it's it's
literally efficiency you know I'm saying
so for me it's like okay if I matter if
I'm now doing this hard content that I
need to drop it'll force to be the black
game I need to take this off because I'm
gonna have to stop these unstoppable so
I'm gonna have to and I think that's the
direction they really want us to go they
don't like us in our little comfort
zones with these you know all the jack
of all trade bills so does me up yeah
was the night fell last week let I
remember the overload as well so I'd
remember those in there because the last
one is pyramidion so and that kind of
ties in when you look at the end of the
artifact we've got basically void and
arc as the main two subclasses that seem
to be tied into the artifact a lot right
now obviously we have arc with Knights
we have solar a little bit but we have
also void all over the place in the raid
index offensive writings like that next
season season of dawn potentially
looking at solar all over the place and
then of course cognitive like praise to
be Osiris please come to us and we need
the god to come back is up very that's
my only beef y'all and I'll leave this
rant I'll keep it very short cuz you
know I'm gonna Cyrus fam but it it just
it puts a hole in my heart that the only
thing that this man is designed to
predict and stop is this one enemy race
and here this enemy race is running
rampant offensive and my man
doesn't even have a piece of what he's
doing we don't know what's going on we
hear nothing about it that burns me so I
am hoping at the end of this expansion
give us like a little how you know maybe
whenever we got the old ring thing like
y'all at the end of a second yeah give
me something that my man is doing you
know I'm saying cuz it really makes no
sense that this man is nowhere to be
found his sole job is to look at the
infinite possibilities of the vex and
and our worst moment this mode is
nowhere to be found
like kobol buns you don't you've already
disrespected me with trials not being
here right I took a personal I'm trying
to get over that don't fish going well
even has like a lot no word from Osiris
or some those say are you serious
Wow this this is this is this is what we
doing huh you just gotta go hang out you
get you and brother Vance can hang out
on Mercury without your sparrows it
wasn't exactly the point - yes listen I
feel like nope I'm out I'm done that
name is just bad news god we gotta get
the sour taste I'll just have you do
something just have him sure say that
he's working on something about him -
what's up what a sham man that's another
one that's the homie where is a Shamir
this effects is his thing unstoppable
impossible
where's my mana so that's all I gotta
say and they look like okay you guys
like acting a little crazy
okay stream may be going crazy but we
definitely are doing a good recording so
yeah so that's most of kind of what I
wanted to cover this week except one
more shiny bright piece of set of armor
it's white it's got some gold flare on
it it's got a little gray undertone to
iron banner wanted to see what you guys
thought about the new armor look man I
like samurai theme as much as like any
other guy but how many top know this new
stuff it's really cool because it's
almost like space themed right like it
Ole Miss it kind of looks like you took
like the this base shaman armor has
dreaming ever that's it mix it with the
iron banner
very nice I like it a lot I think it's
clean very good I claim my only nitpick
with four more like I said as
the helmet to do a little something more
I think y'all like Helms and cool
coolers like my platen Helms got less
going on than yours man mine's almost
smooth yeah I just you know I think
warlocks I'm so used to like you know
point extended things on something more
ominous but don't get me wrong this is
almost clean it kind of worries me cuz
they cut it off at the boots yeah what
is the worst-looking wait there's like a
gif of a rotating right yeah they play
with it now my question for you guys is
once we unlock this this now becomes
part of transmog correct yeah hold on so
it's like we got a few changes about
iron banner so just gonna go through
those real quick yeah go through it so
new season of iron banner there's a new
seasonal pursuit which must be completed
prior to being able to turn in tokens to
purchase packages from lord saladin this
pursuit is character based and will and
rewards the new season eight armor set
each step of the pursuits awards iron
banner weapons and armor most of the
objectives within the pursuit track
progress at any point during the season
of undying even if you have not acquired
the pursuit yet oh that's that's nice
see that that stuff should always be
there like especially when you start
like hey the season the gambit grinder
any of those things should just be like
always tracking all the time please so
in until the seasonal pursuit has been
completed all rewards will be obtained
by completing matches and bounties all
rewards and weapons with until the
seasonal pursuit is complete and then
the existing seven bounties that offered
power rewards have been adjusted to
offer pinnacle rewards 960 max but only
four are available per event that's very
character to you yeah four per character
so you get but for pinnacle drops when
we have the raid we have night falls and
then you have four from PvP that might
beat you many honestly I don't know how
I feel about that I mean I think that
there's one complaint that people saying
it not enough pinnacle activity but yeah
that's a lot no doubt I think the grind
from 950 to 960 is supposed to take a
long time like yeah I don't know we'll
see how hard the bounty so
like what's the way so we have all the
information so yeah I guess the reason
why I guess I may be leaning but you
know again got a shout-out for my PvP
community you know Manny something mean
is that's for sure so it's a PvE drops
but that's where it gets hard it's like
you gotta account for PvE only in PvP
only but the players should do
everything yeah yeah that's where you
get really it gets dangerous right so
mm-hmm
I don't know it's a it's a good point
it's a good point it's a tough one to
balance I think the only thing that I
didn't mention this earlier when talking
about well I clean my shadow keep is
that I've been playing a lot of PvP I've
been I've been doing it and I have to
say this is the most rewarding PvP you
can literally stay in cop or whatever
you're doing and be showered just by
whether it be glory ranks and valor rank
upgrades and you know I got to exotics
one time in one sexy like granite you
know super are in Jesus but you know say
at the end of the day it what you're
like what I like is the time investment
I feel I was like you I could actually
play crucible for a while and not feel
like I'm missing out cuz that's the
other thing like I love core PvP so much
but then if I do I need these powerful
is I need to be getting on my job and
I'm you know I can't be staying in here
too long I literally went up a collect
at least by 10 levels in there one time
I'm like oh this is really rewarding so
after that you know we'll see how banner
comes out it looks great I want to see
if the trans marketing you know goes
down and yeah man I'm excited I'm
excited not another resource yeah I mean
I think I'm with Cairo a little bit just
cuz I feel like for might I mean it's
again it's it would be different if you
were getting like pinnacles from trials
because there's like their skill in
there like you know in these I mean yeah
the bounties you probably have to kill
some people but I don't think the
skilled equates quite the same like a
980 nightfall or the raid or trials even
like just iron banner never has felt
quite of that level and then now you
even have people who are probably gonna
have a bigger disparity in power so some
people are a little slower now 30 versus
like the
in 52s like they're gonna probably have
a harder time of it too
so it's just I don't know it'll be I'll
be interested to see if it makes a
difference I mean if it's like for
people things that take you from like
950 and you're getting like 950 ones
then yeah that thing's gonna be next to
impossible to grind out anyway may not
be that big of a deal but it's just one
of those things per character it's like
there's gonna be a lot of stuff to do it
in one week for three different
characters if you want to play iron
banner trying to get pinnacles you got
to go through the pursuit plus the
bounties like that's a lot of crap just
in PvP slow yeah no you're right you're
right we shall see how it plays out yeah
that will be next week so control does
have a thing they said the heavy ammo
spawning changes made to others will not
be reflected in iron banner that will
daveed next time just they didn't want
to clarify that one they had an
interview with the world's first raid
team by the way shout out to it was clan
ascend and they were doing it but the
number two team behind them less than
three minutes difference yeah that is
crazy they've done that and it was late
I think data was like five minutes on
the last one two with crown of sorrow
it's like how are they it's like the
fact that some of those are so close is
still astounding to me but raid racers
are coming down to two or three minutes
when it's over the course of six hours
like fractions of time here insane it's
just kind of crazy so we are coming up
on a pretty lengthy time because we had
a bit of a late start technical
difficulties and other things but I just
want to respect your time scare oh so we
appreciate it I know we all could
probably talk about stuff for a while
because we're own crazy crazy deep into
this thing for sure another two more
hours I got like but in fairness to
everybody I wanted to work on wrapping
this thing up so man let everybody know
is there anything else you guys want to
talk about before we kind of wrap this
thing up or are you guys in pretty good
shape to move it on I'm trying I think
we covered everything to be honest I
think everything new I mean I could talk
about raids for days that's why we got
you on here is perfect time for it let's
get back behind you for clears as well
man holy crap that's that's the more
glue a flawless tune guys yeah I'll be
waiting to see that tweet man I want to
see it out there
hit a brother up give me your backpack
brother would like a jacket people are
playing this weekend but you tell me
what spot to stand there now I'll put
down the best riff you ever seen look
this man ups Cairo 9 on YouTube he
streams it makes awesome content please
go look him up for sure
what if nothing else you gotta catch his
streams or his videos just to see the
glorious locks of hair mm-hmm yes Jason
the master King you can get the jacket
you got to the 15th brother
yes well I'm trying you see me trying to
make my push mascara right now scalp our
or you go hook a brother up expert run
in there see what the boys are doing I
was like I work Sunday morning but you
know we'll see how things work out but
no and then like we just we appreciate
you have it having you on man it was a
it was a blast thanks for working and
dealing with the difficulties I
apologize of course it's just I can
stream literally all week long and then
I'll host the pot and it was like two
weeks ago is Friday morning completely
other side of the day and it's just like
it's taken up taking a crap in the bed
the entire time and I'm just like what
is happening right now so there will be
video up may have been telling technical
difficulties but you guys will get all
the good stuff I promise most of its
gonna be out there so Cognito yo about
you what is your what is your weekend
hold since we're a little closer to it
for you yeah I'm not gonna try getting
that rate you know I'm saying see who's
a guy's powerful kid
it definitely planted some oil um and um
yeah FX offensive levelling up and then
I already know I love podcasts every
Sunday 11 a.m. during football season so
no guess just the law it's classic
throwback you know I'm saying King with
is gonna have a lot to say clearly yeah
the console gaming so with Sony and then
Microsoft they had some departures as
well talk about all the new stuff we'll
go talk some tech Google stadia you know
I'm saying they're making some very
strong claims you'll address that and we
will also probably talk about the gears
v painting dealing situation so that's a
big yeah that's a whole different topic
of fun for you guys that's that's fun
gaming making like national news and
Senators talking about stuff I was like
yeah that's a topic for another that's a
whole different podcast in itself no but
you're my shop today Chad but yeah
kasaya check us out and of course Lords
of gaming dotnet when you can find all
your latest gaming news all that good
stuff and the last word you already know
generally more Fridays but special night
edition what's Carole in the building
syllabus careful coming through man
always a pleasure always like I was like
best of ask arrow arrays for surgery
that is always a passionate discuss I
love to say hey I appreciate it it's
alright you know so any now we talked so
hopefully next year scarab gcx brother
are already in motion
I already got booked my hotel this week
where do we know the dates already yeah
it's up it's row the hotel blocks with
the special my point for way create your
badges and stuff yet uh I think you can
you gotta be like what you're above me
but you're gonna be like fifty K I think
so project cross their fingers say hey
you and me both man I'm trying I'm
trying to catch up so let's go but yeah
honestly for me Yvonne says every word
twitch Twitter YouTube you guys find me
follow like say hello the gleam giveaway
is going on for a couple more days as
well guys for the stream deck so if you
guys don't have one of those check it
out honestly it's just a really awesome
tool with Ustream play games whatever
I've got a buddy who's got a small one
he uses it for stuff shortcuts and
things it's just honestly it's just a
really cool tool to have I use it
constantly running this thing as well as
like Bigley crucial so
check that one out for you guys um it's
not hard to enter it's pretty easy
actually but other than that I think
that's where we're gonna wrap this thing
up so episode 77 of the last word it's
October 11th the scare oh thank you it
is always an honor we appreciate her
very much keep killing it in the
engineering chemical world and talking
about all your I'm going in here no I'm
not engineering polymer chemistry
because a polymer Kim either way I'm
going into your chat and like getting
the chemistry lesson so I'm just cry all
ways tell myself like oh I'm not it's
your side of me as soon as someone's
like says something that's slightly
wrong I'm got to make it right on
something like as simple as water or
something and then it next thing you
know you're talking about alkynes
[Laughter]
so that is all we got guys thank you
very much so scary we try and in this
thing out if you've ever seen fire to
him team chat they they do something but
it fits the name of ours so it is the
last word we try and say it in sync but
as we're always off it's really hard to
do yes so basically I'm gonna wrap it up
I'm gonna wait for you guys to start
talking I'm gonna try inside the timing
but last time choice of editing I
matched them up so basically we just
like I'm gonna just wrap this thing up
and then I'm gonna say and it has been
and that's where you guys all say the
last word and I'll just try and edit it
thank you guys very much we're gonna
raid man--oh destra after this he was
actually a awesome guy too so check him
out I'm gonna send you guys over there
but it has been episode 77 the last word
October 11 thank you guys very much and
it has been the last word